tu vas nous manquer docteur.  ma parole que je
seconde Avenue Eden à chaque fois que la pièce
Honeyman mal structurée le Donald
Trump mon oeuf animal city tracteur y el
agua est à toute surveillance toute la
gastonia de policía de retour au travail juste
Akutan ma capacité Australie c'est
animal vivant ou caramel sur CD dissing  la
politique mama de police de nouvelle
classe de salsa de singe optique Venkat Rao cervenka
City a appuyé tout Hollywood contre le
déballé a hoché la tête un ultra est cette
direction de l'État victime, nous avons entendu des choses
sur Trump ces derniers jours au cours des
dernières semaines à propos d'
allégations d'agression sexuelle  commentaires qu'il a faits sur toutes
sortes de personnes Noirs mexicains
comment vous sentez-vous à ce sujet vous sentez-vous à l'
aise avec ce qu'il dit en parlant
de ses commentaires prétendument racistes
Je ne pense pas qu'aucun de ces
commentaires soit vraiment raciste ils sont
retirés  du contexte non seulement que ses
commentaires soi-disant misogynes sont également
sortis de leur contexte et je ne
pense pas que vous devriez vraiment le
regarder  néralisations de toutes les femmes,
il ne parle que de certaines femmes et
parle également d'allégations de viol, la plupart
de ces allégations se sont avérées
fausses, comment vous sentez-vous en tant que
partisans ici à New York, c'est assez
dangereux, car vous y arrivez
comme vous obtenez  intimidé beaucoup de gens
qui vous confrontent et des choses comme ça
s'ils découvrent ou aiment si vous
portez d'ici ou quelque chose que vous
allez crier dessus avez-vous été
intimidé un peu, je
me sens vraiment ostracisé d'une certaine manière même s'ils
ne le font pas  ne me crie pas dessus je me sens juste accusé le
juge très durement ici et
aux États-Unis je suis né ici euh tu es
je ne suis pas né j'étais ici pour rouler des
yeux
c'est comme une question de la communauté dites-nous
peut-être pourquoi  vous pourquoi soutenez-vous
simplement de nous expliquer en tant qu'immigrant, je
crois que les immigrants devraient être
soumis à un processus de vérification vigoureux et
moi, Percy, avons subi plusieurs
vérifications des antécédents juste pour arriver ici juste
pour obtenir un statut légal  et je ne pense pas
qu'ils devraient abaisser la norme pour les
autres immigrants personnellement, mes parents
sont venus dans ce pays et ont immigré ici
et vous savez qu'ils ont traversé un
processus d'écriture sévère, il leur a fallu entre
15 et 20 ans pour obtenir la citoyenneté et
c'était  après avoir obtenu une carte verte et comme la
résidence et tout, alors ils sont passés
par le processus pourquoi d'autres personnes ne devraient-elles pas
devenir asiatiques, j'ai l'impression que l'
armée n'a pas vraiment beaucoup de
voix politique en général et j'ai
parlé à un  beaucoup d'agents, qu'ils
soient de la première génération de deuxième génération,
ils ne sentent pas qu'ils doivent participer
au processus politique pensent qu'un
problème majeur dont on ne parle pas
vraiment est le fait qu'il doit y avoir
un ensemble défini dans l'économie
parce que  avec l'augmentation de la
mondialisation, il y a une énorme diminution
du revenu médian, vous savez, dans tout
notre pays et il y a beaucoup plus d'
inégalités de revenus qui se produisent et
ce que Donald Trump veut d  o est proche
que cet écart crée plus d'emplois pour les Américains
et revitalise en quelque sorte l'économie et les
jeunes ne sont complètement pas
intéressés par cette course Je veux dire que beaucoup de
mes amis sont personnellement indifférents à la
politique et j'ai l'impression que même s'ils
viennent  hors vote, ils ne sont pas très
informés sur vous connaissez les
politiques actuelles de chaque candidat et tout au
long de notre chemin, j'ai juste l'impression qu'ils
n'ont pas l'impression que leur voix est
autant valorisée que vous savez qu'ils sont sur les
générations précédentes  vous exprimer